well we have a totally new species of
dinosaur and it's a dinosaur that looks
just like a bird so when you think of
Stegosaurus or Triceratops or t-rex this
is a totally different type of dinosaur
looks like a bird covered in feathers
and it even had wings did it fly well
hahaha that's the million pound question
uh we don't know of course for sure
because this thing lived 125 million
years ago we can't just go out with a
pair of binoculars and go bird-watching
but it probably didn't because it was a
fairly large dinosaur it was about the
size of a mule or so and it had pretty
short arm so it just doesn't seem like
it was the type of animal that would be
very competent in the air so if that's
true then that begs the question well
why did it have wings so why might a
step tub well asked in my own questions
here I think that's the big one you know
and then and it is a question and I'm
asking that question because we don't
know the answer sometimes you find new
fossils and they give you more questions
than answers but probably this dinosaur
was using its wings for display think of
what peacocks do with their tail
feathers they're not fly in with those
things or maybe for protecting its eggs
and it's ness we just don't know for
sure but hey maybe that's why wings
actually evolved in dinosaurs maybe they
evolved for display and then only later
did that dainese dinosaurs start to use
them when they were flying and when they
turned into birds oh maybe I've seen it
described today as a fluffy feathered
poodle from hell what was it was it her
very or is it possible to tell how good
a predator it was you know years ago I
worked as a journalist so I think you
can see maybe where some of these
expressions are coming from and it was a
fluffy feathered poodle from hell
because it had feathers and it was a
pretty scary nasty predator this was a
dynast for about two meters long about
20 kilograms sharp claws on its hands
even bigger claws on its feet about
50-60 steak knife teeth in its skull so
this was not a dinosaur you would want
to run into even though it might look
like
in a funny-looking chicken this was
something that would've taken you down
and just finally Steve is that lots of
frantic work continuing in this area to
try and on earth more if it if this one
was so beautifully preserved you know I
wish I could say that I found this would
have been the absolute highlight of my
career but it was found by a farmer in
northeastern China and I was invited to
help study it by my good friend jin
cheng luo and beijing one of china's top
dinosaur hunters and june chang and his
colleagues they're always on the lookout
for new fossils this is one of the most
productive parts of the world we're
getting about 25 new species of dinosaur
out of China every year so it's very
exciting I'm in Edinburgh we have a
great collaboration with our friends in
China and who knows what we're gonna
find next mmm